you
[Music]
I'm how a lot of you might know me as
the developer of cable extra but today I
won't tell anything about Quebec I will
tell you how we can use our spirit
add-in to improve our lives
I mean learning for ourselves but also
for the teams that you're working in so
here are the links to the slides and
also to some code examples we're gonna
discuss later feel free to write it down
take a picture I hope I can make it
bigger
I should have what's that
so before I start my talk I want to give
you guys a little bit information about
who who we are and our technical
infrastructure I'm working this
institution and we are a group of Asian
researchers located in basta we don't
have a very big data group and but we
have a very diverse background
in terms of culture and training and we
love everything our speaker made and we
are a big fan of like our CEO server and
we have our self host ERC server and we
also have connect and so how many people
sitting here have used our CEO add-ins
before like just pretty much yeah great
so for those who have never tried it
before or see you add in they are these
little buttons on this drop-down menu
that is accessible so by clicking these
Eddins button around your toolbar here
are some facts so our series release
this feature about two years ago and I
won't read through all these saying that
but the the primary goal of our CRN's to
help us as data sized
oh you're not your manager well if your
manager is using our CEO you might use
our settings as well but it's something
I want to shout out here is I our CEO at
ends it has to be delivered in the form
of our packages one our package can hold
multiple it is but something I want to
echo here is I don't be afraid of terms
like developing our package I will show
you later on that this thing is super
super simple you can do it like within
one unit and you can even try it out
tonight after this talk so in this talk
first of all we are gonna start with a
very basic introduction of how we can
create our see you add in
and I'm gonna show you a few events we
created at our workplace and some
errands we love from the community let's
start last week I sent out a tweet on
Twitter by let me show you this add-in
it's called a switch or using switch RC
using if you click the hat your ghost be
dark if you click it again or ghost py
this feature is super helpful for me
because I mean if I'm doing all my
programming job I hope I like dark steam
Hatter hacker but sometimes if I want to
show my results to my co-workers I don't
like to show the white normal version of
me so it seems like a lot of people on
Twitter they are very curious about like
how can we make this same in that we are
in that tweet I was saying like we can
actually make this thing within one
minute
so let's now see how we can do that so
basically what we are trying to do here
is so this is a our she's options like
global options where you can set the
seems we we are what we are trying to do
is like we are gonna switch between
these clouds and cloud midnight midnight
that goes so the first step so here I'm
gonna talk about the first step of
creating this edit the first thing I
want to mention I want to like put this
into your mind that to the end RC
add-ins they are just are functions
everything you can do is in our function
you can do it like you can just follow
it with a button our steel and make it
an add-in so we use these are steel API
package there's a function called get in
for and we see it tells us the name of
the same we are currently using and
there's an option called dark and tell
right now is well what I was rendering
this document it was false and then we
did some very basic in this it should be
the first class in first class in y'all
like our cars like how do you do this we
assign this value to current theme if
this one is true if this dark is true
then we goes to clouds if dark is false
and we discriminate and we assign that
value to the next thing and after that
we there is another function magic
function in the RC API called apply them
and we send that value to this function
so we can already do that in three lines
of code and we after that we just wrap
it up with a function call and we save
it somewhere in the our folder so that's
how a first step very easy right
everyone gets it right and now you have
a function that is working in fact if
you run that function inside your
console you will just change your cesium
and now you want you you are still to
know that okay we have a din that is
available all you want you bind it with
something how can we do that inside this
read after me that inst our studio
audience the DCF write the following
four lines of code name something which
is a named USC in the buttons
description which is message who you
will see when you hover your mouse over
and binding this is the most important
one it tells you which are functioning
well drawn and interactive well if your
it has an interface then it's
interactive otherwise fuss so here is a
minimal structure for our steel and in
like package so we have this our file we
just talked about and these add-ins the
DCF is where we define these headings
and then we have a description for those
who have ever tried to write our package
I mean you know that we need
description fire to be a package
basically it has some information i kudo
this package how can we call it things
like that don't be worried about it
and there's even a function in use death
that will help you to set up a new
package within one line of code so only
three files and dirty like after we have
these three files you can have an
editing that is possible that is like
doing the things someone think it will
be a magical effect and another example
i'm gonna show you here is like
bookmarks you might wonder why we need a
bookmark because I mean we have
bookmarks in you know in the browser it
works perfectly but uh if if you are
working inside a big group or if you are
your your well for example my workplace
I am our CI administrator and I we after
we set it up this our studio server
there are some certain information you
want other people to know for example
where can we access the shared drive and
we're like where is our gift server so
in the end I wrote a documentation using
book down and we publish down the arse
you connect however I cannot control
other people's like browser right I just
cannot hack into their computer and do
those things well something I can do is
I can wrote up our package and pack this
link up as a button and pin it are the
on the top of their alienist so in the
end I can just send them my email say ok
do you see that button in the in the
arse you you click that and click the
second link you will be brought to a
documentation site you got for you guys
who have you spoke down before they
booked an email support search if they
have any issues you can just go ahead
and search it
very simple feature but it's proven to
be very useful for a lot of our
colleagues guess how many lines of code
we need we only need one lines of code
there is a function coder
or capi viewer and just put that link in
and that's it that's very one of code
that was solve your issue and one issue
I have with our cereal is AG if you are
really a big re-adding fan you installed
a lot of fancy add-ins in the end you
will have something well this is my work
machine so not that crazy you have a
head in like this like that although RC
you provide us like a search feature but
and I hate you type you know so I want
something that can help us to pin my
favorite add-in at the very top for
those people who are wearing green
shirts like RC people that here is a
feature request please please do that
but for now what you can do is that you
can react sport these awesome aliens
from other packages by simply another
once again another one live code for
example I really like you guys shutting
the package and there is a infinite moon
reader at in so basically what I do is
like I execute this function well I'm
not I'm tagging the function name here
and I assign it to to this open checking
a function I just run way created and
that's it you can you can do that very
just by doing that so you may wonder how
can I know which which function was a
function that was called by the idea one
track is like if you for example here if
you execute the original infinite moon
reader and you will see okay well I'm
not inside that book down folder but you
are see this is a function just copy it
paste it into your function that you you
name it and then define like the exist
of set of C said in and that's it that's
everything you need to do so I already
show you three easy example but this one
is a kind of a complicated one I put it
here because I feel like reference
management saying it's always tricky for
a lot of us when we are trying to write
our markdown so our solution is use a
combination of our cross-reference which
is from our open side and this side are
from federal cost that federal cost
sorry if I didn't pronounce it right so
let me show you example USC and I in
this demo I provided you see I created a
internal package and I export and reacts
vote so right now is pin at the top of
my list also one trick I want to mention
here is like for your package you you
definitely there is a very simple but
dirty kind of dirty trick started with
an A so you so first step is that you
start this add in from cross-reference
and you see it has a shiny it has an
interactive interface which is created
by shiny and the example I want to try
here
for those who attended the Yamaha
workshop you might have already seen
this but uh let me search Hardy's tidy
data Internet okay I find the first one
and you see there is a link you can
click this link to make sure that is
right copy and you see I got links to
this Journal of statistical software so
okay we find the right one right and we
can click this button add to my
citations and after a while since he's
using Oh like behind things using all
this API call it says added well it
takes longer today but uh yeah if we
connect this we will be able to see okay
this bit of text file has is already
added here and just by searching and if
we create a new our markdown document
if we want to cite this this citation
hardest ID data which is awesome paper I
recommend everybody to read we can use
these hand in from side are so basically
what it does is like it goes into this
file and then find all these are studio
find all these references you can
basically just connect that and insert
citation and that's it that's I'm just
putting in here it's a great example to
show you how you can complete this kind
of complex task by using add-ins ok
let's go back to our talk we have
several other use adding use cases I
would just quickly go through them I we
don't have any enough time to go through
them one by one
but as so for example for the first one
I mean as Adam as a RC MN we need to we
sometimes need to tell or say for those
people who use ODBC to connect to
different like database we know that we
can set up our profile inside this
header file the data ODBC I file and
then you can just use our studios
connection panel to connect to different
database just by clicking it was it's
really freaky like in any version of our
studio before one point to preview that
our our CEO like in previously it is not
possible well it's not very easy to
access header files but right now there
is an option to turn it now but still it
won't be easier to tell your colleagues
to click a button on the our studio at
in panel and that button will bring up
these I file and you can just send them
these login credentials and they will
just put that in variant put those
information and they will be able to
connect to desired database without too
much headache on training
we also develop some errands too
we installed a cave an alternative to
madaba which are just money too
so we installed alternate we installed
an octave on this server and we have an
add-in that basically just starts a
terminal using the RCO api the terminal
section it starts that starts a terminal
and then start these octave
automatically for me one trick is like
surely if you want to send commands from
our accounts from the text editor to our
console you hit command enter and this
thing is I think it's out command enter
am I getting it wrong but you can check
say Aki
oh yeah and something I want to mention
here is about this r2 cluster package
that we are currently developing because
for those who are working academia like
sometimes we need to use a need to
access like some high performance
cluster to do some really like
computation no heavy work these kind of
things it's like if you use it every day
you know how to use it if you don't use
it if you just use it for one time then
it's okay to go through all the
documentation but then in the worst
Keith case is like you use it every once
awhile and I keep forgetting how do you
do that so basically we create these
add-in that will help us so we use shiny
modules so basically it will save your
username and some like ports these kind
of things within your home directory and
use this information to help you to log
in and it has pre-populated commands
here and when you click this play button
you will send these commands to our your
terminal and execute it like you have
the option that was are not you execute
it but uh yeah you get the idea and also
it has like a panel to help us to
request certain service I mean if you
have used this species before you know
that this
that's complicated that's why we need
this edit so take home messages first
say like if I can only do like prison
for like 10 seconds hour only say these
singing loud creating our society is
really really easy and it's really
really fun if you find that okay there
are a lot of fancy aliens well that's
not because creating a ditz difficulties
because why it's easier China or is does
a lot of like amazing our jobs and
behind the thing it's not anything super
easy you can do it tonight
second because it's so easy you can even
do it like for personal use
in fact I I I feel like for a lot of us
I mean I started as a very plain like
our user before I did not develop our
packages until yeah four years ago but
if you have never created on our package
it is actually a very good starting
point although it sounds weird about it
it is a very good starting point because
in this case you don't need to work
since these for your personal use you
don't need to worry about any
documentation so you don't need to worry
about namespace and a lot of these kind
of freaky things get started tonight and
do it I already show you the code and
yeah also if you are working a big group
this is a great tool for teams to form
standardized practice because I mean
keeping good documentation we always
know that keeping good organization is
the key to success for a team but if you
have if like if you compare them measure
like you give someone a page of that
steps to follow or you write an ad in
that packs off these ten steps on that
page I which one is easier of course
like I would rather just click a button
right and really in the end I would just
want to give credit to my teammates
especially these three gentlemen they
stay on the left side and our money
provider
and thank you
[Applause]
so we have time for a few questions for
hound my colleague over here will throw
the throw the throw bowl microphone over
to whoever has a question let's go back
there thanks man definitely learned a
lot from that talk I was learning if
there are any other features that you
feel like a lacking or that I'll see you
could improve with a dance apart from
that one that you mentioned well some
features well it's it's actually not
about I add in itself but rather our CEO
API because yeah because an ins can
interact with the interface with the
Ostia interface through the RC API if we
can have more options open through the
API although in my son's risky but it
might give us more options to to do with
it at it were open seven tons of fun and
tons of possibility
[Music]